en los últimos días hemos hablado de la
devaluación de varias monedas de los
países de nuestra región frente al dólar
y de la posible recesión económica a la
que el mundo se pudiera enfrentar así
como de la alta inflación sin embargo
hay algunos países los que pareciera que
la crisis global no les ha afectado el
precio de la canasta familiar al menos
por ahora como es el caso de bolivia por
ejemplo que acumula un alza de precios
del 1.2 por ciento en lo corrido de este
año 2022 y que celebra que sea una de
las más bajas de américa latina'
por su parte el presidente alistarse
dice que son un ejemplo y le atribuyó a
su manejo económico pero hay quienes
dicen que se debe a otros factores que
otros factores serán pues se lo vamos a
preguntar por supuesto a nuestro primer
invitado del día el es gonzalo chávez
economista la universidad católica
boliviana quien también nos acompaña en
esta mesa de trabajo para hablar de este
tema económico pues por supuesto daniela
blandón daniela bienvenido buen día
gracias raúl muy buenos días y veremos
también que esto parece ser una buena
noticia pero al final no es tan buena
noticia para algunos países y se le
vamos a preguntar entonces a gonzalo no
pues señor gonzález el saludando le muy
buenos días primero quisiera saber cómo
porque bolivia tiene una inflación tan
baja y el resto de países tienen una
inflación tan alta
bueno mi bolivia tiene estabilidad de
los precios desde el año 86 cuando
tuvimos una inflación de 11 mil por
ciento gobiernos de derecha izquierda
han creído que la estabilidad es un
patrimonio nacional y han seguido con
esas políticas en los últimos años en
los últimos 15 años del gobierno de evo
morales y de arce catacora la inflación
ha sido sumamente baja por dos razones
sobre todo en primer lugar porque
tenemos subsidios muy grandes a la
gasolina la gasolina cuesta 0 50
centavos de dólar el litro y tenemos
subsidios a varios alimentos tal vez el
más importante es el pan cuyo precio
también es sumamente bajo entonces eso
reprime la inflación de manera
significativa son los subsidios el
segundo elemento que muestra porque hay
inflación el ensayo es tan baja en
bolivia tiene que ver con la mantención
del tipo de cambio
del nominal y una apreciación del tipo
de cambio real eso significa que al
tener el tipo de cambio en dólares
especialmente fijo bolivia es capaz de
importar muchos productos y servicios de
afuera muy bajos que ayudan a mantener
la inflación entonces son esas dos
razones que hacen que la inflación sea
sumamente baja y por supuesto estas son
buenas noticias para la economía
boliviana en el corto plazo pero en
algún momento deberíamos sincerar los
problemas fiscales y los problemas
cambiarios que tienen la economía
boliviana eso le quería preguntar a
gonzalo digamos hasta cuánto hasta qué
punto estos subsidios son sostenibles
hemos visto también por ejemplo un país
también de nuestra región venezuela
donde el gobierno ha subsidiado por
mucho tiempo muchísimos productos entre
ellos la gasolina y pues ya se vio que
esto no era sostenible y ya la gasolina
está digamos tratando de llegar a un
precio internacional evidentemente lo
han podido hacer abruptamente pero pues
ha demostrado en varios casos que no es
sostenible en un largo plazo no tanto
subsidio
mira si evidentemente los subsidios
funcionan en la medida que tienes
recursos por ejemplo y gran parte de los
recursos parecidos con venezuela en
bolivia para el sector público vienen de
hidrocarburos entonces bolivia el año
2014 exportaba 6.500 millones de dólares
de gas natural a brasil y argentina e
importaba mil millones de dólares y eso
le daba unos ingresos al estado
boliviano de más o menos 5 mil millones
de dólares que ha pasado el año pasado
ya está las exportaciones de gas han
bajado a un tercio dos mil 269 millones
de dólares y las importaciones han
subido a 2.250 entonces tu superávit que
eran 5500 millones de dólares ahora es
de 19 millones de dólares entonces por
supuesto los subsidios funcionan en la
medida en que tú tienes ingresos
tributarios el estado boliviano hace 9
años tiene déficit público entonces cada
vez hay menos recursos y por lo tanto
este tipo de políticas públicas de
sustentar precios y bajos con subsidios
tiene piernas cortas por supuesto lo que
hay que hacer es cambiar la forma de
financiamiento del emshi público buscar
nuevas fuentes de ingreso buscar nuevos
ricos en fuentes de dólares digamos esté
diversificando exportaciones pero caso
contrario pues es la vieja historia de
américa latina que por un momento
tenemos subsidios eso pasó con alan
garcía pasó con venezuela pasó con
argentina con muchos países los
subsidios funcionan en la medida que
tienen la plata para poder aplicarlos
eso se acaba y las cosas se complican
pero bolivia está en el momento de poder
hacer una transición de los recursos que
antes venían masivamente el sector
hidrocarburos a otros sectores para que
otros sectores paguen impuestos en
bolivia señor chávez también hay un
fenómeno que es la deflación que es
cuando los precios no suben sino que
bajan e incluso llegó a pasar en bolivia
en uno de estos meses de febrero a marzo
hubo deflación en japón es un país donde
ha habido deflación también
históricamente pero también hay
problemas con que los precios no suban
sino que bajen todo el mundo pensaría
que
lo ideal sería que los precios bajarán
pero cuáles son esos problemas de que en
los países bajen los precios en lugar de
subir
bueno generalmente cuando bajan los
precios significa que no estás pudiendo
vender no siento que tienes problemas
con la producción que tienes problemas
con la oferta y eso ocurre en el caso
boliviano en algunos sectores que
todavía siguen muy deprimidos a raíz de
la crisis del cobi 19 y que el como es
caso de gastronomía como es el caso del
turismo hay unos sectores que han subido
muchísimo pero hay otros que todavía
siguen en recesión ahora no nos
olvidemos también que en el caso
boliviano es muy particular que si bien
la economía se ha recuperado
parcialmente a el año pasado creció a
6.1 por ciento y el empleo ahora es 4.2
el 80 por ciento de la población
económicamente activa en bolivia está
ocupada en el sector informal en un
sector de muy baja calidad donde está en
salida de ocupaciones y trabajos de
sobrevivencia y por supuesto en ese
contexto los precios tienen a ser muy
bajos en esos sectores porque bolivia
importa muchísimas cosas las
importaciones de bolivia legales y
legales y el año 2000
4 era aproximadamente unos dos mil a
tres mil millones entonces ha subido a
doce mil millones de dólares ahora
entonces una economía abierta que vive
también artificialmente con el tema del
tipo de cambio fijo y el real apreciado
y eso depende de dólares de hecho las
reservas internacionales en bolivia que
estaban alrededor de 15 mil millones de
dólares el
2014 han bajado ahora a 4 mil 702
bolivia tienen que resolver sus temas de
subsidios y tienen que conseguir divisas
para poder mantener esta inflación baja